the Joe Rogan experience yeah this like
it's an endless source of fascination
like wildlife documentaries to me are
just truly an endless source of
fascination there I mean you don't you
preach in the choir but yeah I think
they're phenomenal you there's just so
much we can learn and it's like it's
more than just what we learned oh that's
cool that's a nice fact about an octopus
but you know we took how we shaped jets
off of the shape of birds we've taken so
much inspiration from nature into our
everyday lives
look at this look at this squid skin
squids get this so squid or check oh my
god it's like a television yeah like the
pixels on a television I didn't know
squid could do that - oh this is so
weird oh god they're so strange such a
strange strange animal but the ocean is
so bizarre in and of itself there's just
so many weird creatures on the ocean
it's such an alien environment to us as
terrestrial mammals do you remember when
the tsunami hit Thailand and then there
was all these animals that they were
finding that they had never really seen
before washed up on the shores I
remember that yeah yeah and they were
documenting them there was a whole
website dedicated to scene tsunami
deep-sea creatures I didn't know that
yeah yes really crazy like some of these
things that are living you know a
[ __ ] mile down under the earth and
you're like what what are you and they
they forget what the number was but they
got like 30 or 40 new species or
something crazy like that literally like
combing through the streets of the
cities where these where the tsunami had
hit yeah is that a richer source of
bioresources of the the ocean of a
biodiversity I should say the ocean then
earth oh there's more life in the ocean
than on terrestrial land for sure yeah
you mean is there more diversity in
general weirdness
oh yeah there's way more I I guess it
depends how you define weirdness but I
look at an octopus look at a cuttlefish
you know look at those deep sea
creatures crabs and all the way into the
marine mammals and all the way down to
the tiny little insects or isopods that
live in the ocean I think I think the
ocean creatures are very bizarre how
about those giants
quit that they found on that oil tanker
yeah they saw that one giant squid with
the crazy like crab leg yep that one
likes maybe not never see that one with
the crab legs is he walking along the
bottom no it's got like it looks like it
has appendages well with the joints yeah
haven't seen oh my god a woman to show
you something I'm learning a lot today I
like this crazy alien looking squid
what's up I found the thing about those
pictures they've been gone around
multiple times after tsunamis apparently
they don't have anything to do with the
tsunami they are just there are real
photographs of real strange sea
creatures they just didn't wash up on
shore after tsunami what about the thing
that you'd saw that's what I said what I
was 2004 in 2011 same photos also people
are bullshitting Russians go to pull up
that alien squid discovered near oil rig
so they had a camera deep under this oil
rig and they spotted this thing with
these insane long appendages look at
this oh whoa yeah that's different
I thought you look at the [ __ ] length
of those what are those things that
dangle from it what do you would you
call those things tentacles legs legs
what is it but look at the legs on it
like an insect that's very bizarre see
how they have like very like obvious
bends video courtesy of shale oil
company doing a good job for nature yeah
I see the deep there's another one is
that another but look how weird it is
how it has like a clear bends like when
you see that thing underwater floating
around like that like that looks like an
alien
totally totally that is that is our
exact kind of depiction of what an alien
species go to that green one right next
to it yeah look at that like look at
that that's crazy I mean if you saw that
underwater you would [ __ ] your pay
hundred percent 100 percent and it's a
hundred feet yes it's huge it's nuts I
mean is it that big how big they say it
was when we get that up didn't they say
the tentacles go crazy long it looks
like it yeah they said though
thing was enormous but that the length
of the actual tentacles whatever the
[ __ ] it is was really long so strange
and this before they got this video
footage of it they didn't even know if
something like this was real and there's
there's like a lot of those where you
get these deep-sea cameras and you're
like oh there's a species we haven't
ever documented before so it's in the
Gulf of Mexico they caught a depth of
seven thousand eight hundred feet but
they did what does it say how big they
think it is you can just type in 9 mag
fins weena the squid size BIG's big fin
like a [ __ ] just so weird it look
like the the way that the head of it
sort of pulsates and moves with right
waves like it's like a Steven Spielberg
creation yeah there's that and then
there's also a puppy right you know
that's how diverse life is okay the
length is up to 15 to 20 times the
mantle 20 26 feet okay that's four more
or more yeah well giant octopus is -
right giant squids were thought to be
[ __ ] until like fairly recently
wrecked yeah I don't know when
specifically but they've found a few
that have washed up and then they got
some they got some actual footage of
some that's what I thought you were
talking about I want some rigs Daisy
what about octopi what's the largest of
the octopi the Giant Pacific octopus so
the species that you saw attacking that
Eagle that's not a huge one but as far
as as far as I know that's the largest
one yeah that's a giant squid it's a big
cephalopod oh that thing's huge
that looks like it's more than 28 feet
if you stretch that [ __ ] out no those
ones those ones are those ones are like
a hundred plus feet okay that's what I'm
quit yeah a hundred plus feet they can
get up to that yeah it is so nuts
isn't it a hundred foot jelly creature
you know and you know what's interesting
is sperm whales will leave the surface
of the ocean and dive down to their
depths to hunt those that's what they
Laurie Oh mah reez good look at that
[ __ ] so weird
so the the large Pacific octopus how big
Giants Giant Pacific octopus how BIG's
that guy yet
um I don't know and I mean you know cuz
they're fan-out so I'm not sure maybe 5
feet long 6 feet long but heavy like 40
50 60 pounds something like that they've
got a really big one of the Monterey Bay
Aquarium really yeah really cool one oh
I've been to that I've been to that
aquarium back in the day yeah the legend
of the Kraken like they used to think
that was all total horseshit right until
they found some fossilized cups they
found some suction cups mhm that were
the you know some fossilized evidence of
enormous cups right that they think are
indicative of this you know real hundred
foot octopus or [ __ ] octopus well or
just 100 foot squid on the surface you
know what I like you said those stories
always get embellished so even if it was
a 60 foot squid on the surface say it
was injured or dying and it was alive
and the boat hit it and it starts
slapping the boat with its with its
tentacles all night it's to crack and
like that's not gonna turn into a crazy
sea fable you imagine though if you were
one of those dudes that was like making
your way across the ocean and you you
know in the eleven hundreds or some [ __ ]
and you jump in the water to wash off
and you get eaten by a giant octopus in
front of your friends yeah that's
it's literally suction cups that rip you
apart it's crazy and it's totally
possible that those things were huge we
just don't have the fossil evidence
because they're all made of jelly right
you know they're just like they don't
fossilize yeah yeah yeah all you get is
like if you those fossilized the images
of the the the the cups is just because
it left an imprint writing some sort of
soil right at the bottom of the ocean
[Applause]